hi dr. Berg here I realized the last
webinar that I did is about an hour long
so some of you might not watch it so I
wanted to create a quick summary of the
webinar that I just did ok so we talked
about stress and that's the first thing
we want to talk about so stress
activates a hormone called cortisol
cortisol would be considered like liquid
stress and what it does is it basically
creates adaptations to your body so your
body can adapt to stress so it affects
the muscle the bone the brain the
kidneys the blood sugars so if you're
being chased by a tiger
you're gonna actually run on sugar so
you're gonna spike your sugar that's so
chronic stress leads to diabetes because
of that effect it's going to create
mental focus acuity because you know
you're being chased by a tiger you're
gonna be mentally acute but you don't
want that when you're sleeping when
you're thinking about stress all that
long and then over time when cortisol
goes higher the little receptors that
receive cortisol in the different parts
of the body they start to become
resistive because too much cortisol is
very very damaging to the brain for
memory and and you name it and then so
the effects becomes less and less and
less so you have this high amount of
cortisol but no benefits from the
cortisol so you get belly fat that you
get inflammation because the dream of
the cortisol is an anti-inflammatory and
that's why they give you cortisol or
steroids or prednisone for him to
planetory conditions because you run out
even despite your blood tests being
normal or high see how that works so
someone's talking but no one's listening
the same exact thing happens with the
pink risk when it pumps up insulin the
liver receptors become very resistant
they call the insulin resistance that's
type 2 diabetes so they give you drugs
metformin and glucophage which is the
same thing that makes that receptor dial
and get bigger so the instant works now
but why don't you just cut down the
sugar that would do the same thing or
better
so really what happens with chronic
stress is it can affect a lot of
different things
autoimmune stuff all autoimmune problems
occur after an injury if you ask anyone
when did it start what happens is it
just before there'll be a loss of a
loved one a divorce a stress and injury
you name it it's a stress event okay
autoimmune what is the only treatment
for autoimmune prednisone
what is beforeit prednisone cortisol
it's all the same thing so of course I
was very destructive to your immune
system to your bones the collagen your
blood sugars your proteins of your leg
your belly fat your minerals your memory
sleep apnea high cholesterol high blood
pressure allergies asthma all these
conditions that's the cortisol that's a
stress effect so in medicine what
they're doing is they're taking the
disease and treating them separately
they're not looking at the foundational
underlying cause of all these symptoms
these are symptoms these are stress
effects so there's side effects of
stress and then I also talked about what
to do there are several things you can
do from a nutrient standpoint the number
one nutrient for stress would be vitamin
b1 but you have to be careful because
most of its synthetic so you want to get
a natural b1 I'm going to be coming out
with an adrenal day formula which has a
natural b1 a couple of weeks but in the
meantime I would recommend getting
nutritional yeast take a heaping
teaspoon and some yogurt every single
day that will help let stress especially
mental stress because stress depletes b1
so does sugar
so does refined carbohydrates we talked
about the best exercise for stress would
be walking why because you've increased
oxygen and you get your attention going
out versus trying to all that long we're
trying to counter stress we need a lot
of oxygen low stress walking is the
absolute best thing okay and then I also
talked about the number-one place on
your body that holds most the stress
would be right up here in the Atlas it's
the first cervical vertebra
and there's a technique even when you
download the manual I gravy your link
down there we sure you you can use a
tool or you can use your hands if you go
all the way down I'll show you I give
you links on the video so if you go to
that link
I think it's dr. Burke massage tool
manual massage - torment - manual give
you videos on how to do it with the tool
without but I created this tool for my
own body since I have practitioners but
usually I'm the guy that's fixing
everyone and so I'm the last guy to get
any help with my body so I developed
this this is my best friend because I
can lay back on my couch and hit these
points and just pull this dress right
out within two minutes so right back
here if there's any practitioners
watching or doctors it's called the
parasympathetic the part of the vagus
nerve and the raphe nuclei but if
there's but if anyone else just forget
what I just said all that means is that
this is the turn off switch to help you
go to sleep at night and you lay back on
the couch melt the stress and I show you
seven other places in the manual that
you can download of how to use this on
the different places and your body to
pull stress out every night and then I
showed everyone how to do a technique
how to get rid of like red shoulder pain
left shoulder pain low back pain plantar
fasciitis in a very unique way okay so
you'll like that alright so you can
download that stuff and then the last
thing that I suggested if you don't have
this tool and you want to get it I gave
you a coupon code to get 10% off and
then plus if you get it and then write a
review on Amazon an unbiased review I
don't want to care if it's whatever it
is I'm gonna send you as a nice little
thank you my advanced acupressure
do-it-yourself program with all the
techniques it's for hours as manuals on
each it will send you a link because
I'll see your review and I'll actually
catch your name and send you that link
it's normal it's four hundred ninety
five dollars on my website you can have
it for free because I'm trying to get
reviews
Amazon all right so that's only good to
the end of the earth all right so I hope
you enjoy the summary click the link
down below and start applying these
techniques on your body all right that's
the summary